en février 2022 on vous a raconté la
triste histoire de Fernand Larouche un
retraité dont les épargnes se sont
subitement volatilisés après qu'il soit
tombé dans le piège tendu par des
fraudeurs qui lui faisait miroiter
d'aller champs profit obtenu grâce au
crypto monnaie tout ce que j'ai investi
je l'ai perdu c'était tout près d'un
million
un an plus tard le constat est désolant
rien n'a changé pire les arnaques du
genre sont en augmentation et les
victimes comme Fernand Larouche se
comptent par milliers
[Musique]
après la diffusion de l'émission l'année
passée
j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages de gens
qui ont été floués comme moi par les
mêmes escrocs
ma maison je l'ai vendu au dessus de
400000 j'étais super contente parce que
je peux être tout toutes mes dettes et
en plus j'avais un 200000 puis là j'ai
tout perdu j'ai perdu mon 200000 puis je
m'étais
réendettée d'à peu près 40 à 50 000
en moyenne les victimes si je me fais à
l'année passée ça représente un moyen au
moins 70 000 dollars par victime Jeff
Nicolas dans un monde idéal on serait
pas ici à parler des publicités
frauduleuses sur Facebook un an après
votre enquête là-dessus on est encore
dans cet univers là il s'est même pire
un an plus tard après notre enquête
l'année dernière ce qu'on se rencontre
c'est que les fraudes associés à la
crypto monnaie au Canada ont doublé en
2022 donc on parle de près de 100
millions de dollars qui ont été volés à
des Canadiens et ça c'est vraiment le
minimum parce que le 133 du Canada
a déterminé que c'est entre 5 et 10% des
victimes de fraude qui vont signaler
seulement aux autorités on parle
vraiment des gens qui perdent absolument
tout dans ces fraudes-là qui partent en
grande majeure partie sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est encore le même stratagème
que leur dernier globalement c'est
surtout sur facebook qu'on voit ce
publicité trompeuse là mais ça peut être
sur plusieurs plateformes dont Google
duolingo YouTube et autres mais bon
concentrez-vous sur Facebook c'est là
que ça se passe plus souvent c'est
simple des publicités vont apparaître
sur les fils des gens qui leur disent
qu'il y en a une occasion en marbre pour
investir avec cryptomonnaie en général
on va voir une image d'une célébrité sur
ces publicités là comme Ivan musk qu'on
a aussi vu des publicités avec Justin
Trudeau le chef de l'opposition pierre
poillière la joueuse de tennis bien
connu de la Fernandez et d'autres
figures canadiennes l'annonce veut dire
que cette célébrité là a créé une
plateforme pour trouver un secret pour
faire de l'argent on clique sur la pub
ça nous amène vers un faux article donc
par exemple aux couleurs de la presse ou
d'autres médias canadiens comme le
Toronto Star et on peut alors entrer nos
informations comme notre nom notre
numéro de téléphone un agent nous
appelle pour nous guider dans un
investissements en crypto monnaie
l'argent semble fructifier sur la
plateforme et au moment où on veut
retirer ben on peut pas retirer l'argent
était volé c'est une fraude pur et
simple la crypto-monnaie c'est juste un
véhicule là dedans pour la fraude il y a
pas d'argent qui est réellement investi
là
qui date depuis plus de 10 ans c'est bon
ça a commencé en Israël comme disait
Nicolas la crypto c'est juste un
prétexte pour aller chercher les gens
les victimes oui le on parle de crypto
arnaque aujourd'hui parce que c'est
lapin qui est le plus souvent utilisé de
nos jours mais ce sont pas des
investissements crypto c'est de la
fraude pure et simple on vole votre
argent et le dénominateur commun dans
lequel qui nous occupe c'est Facebook
c'est la porte d'entrée pour cette
fraude là ce qu'on a constaté l'an
dernier c'est que vraiment une fois
qu'on était visé par ces publicités là
notre fil était inondé de publicité de
la sorte et un an plus tard non
seulement nos fils sont encore inondés
par ces publicités là c'est souvent les
mêmes publicités que l'an dernier et
même les faux articles vers lesquels
même ces publicités là spécifiquement
des articles de la presse apparaissent
encore très souvent dans notre enquête
de l'an dernier on constaté que les
personnalités publiques dont l'image
était
usurpée pour attirer les victimes vers
ces arnaques en ligne était
principalement de grosses point comme
ilon musk ou encore des politiciens mais
nous avons récemment vu apparaître des
publicités qui s'approprient l'identité
de personnalités québécoises comme notre
collègue gérald Fillion ou encore
l'animateur qui a Lepage quand j'ai vu
que mon image était utilisée sur les
réseaux sociaux pour mon Dieu pour de la
fraude moi c'est sûr que si tu utilises
mon nom puis tu vas sacrer ça sur sur ma
page facebook ou bien que tu mets mon
adresse les gens cliquent dessus c'est
sûr que sur 500 000 abonnés il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont tomber dans le
panneau
ça devient moins le responsable
finalement je suis même pas la victime
collatérale c'est parce qu'il me
connaissent c'est parce qu'il m'aime ou
parce qu'ils ont pensé que c'était vrai
qui ont cliqué sur mon nom
je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de laxisme
du côté des Facebook et Twitter pour ne
pas les nommer les amis mon nom parlait
des membres du public m'ont écrit pour
me dire j'ai vu ça il y a beaucoup de
gens dans la société pour toutes sortes
de raisons non pas beaucoup de
littératie financière donc on vient
abuser carrément de certaines personnes
qui n'ont pas nécessairement la capacité
de discriminer et de déterminer très
exactement ce qui est vrai ce qui est
faux parce que ce qui est faux a l'air
de plus en plus vrai et c'est ça qui est
très inquiétant si les publicités
usurpins l'identité de personnalité
publique se multiplient et se
diversifient depuis un an le procédé
comme tel lui est le même il est
identique l'année dernière on avait nous
-mêmes testé une de ces arnaques après
avoir cliqué sur une publicité utilisant
l'image d'IDL mask Nicolas avait été
redirigé vers un faux article du Toronto
Star ou apparaissait une offre
d'investissement en crypto monnaie
quelques minutes seulement après cette
inscrit en ligne Nicolas recevait
l'appel de supposer conseillers
financiers
[Musique]
contenu viennent la publicité et le
publicité frauduleuses là-dedans
contribue à ses revenus là Facebook dit
que les dommages qu'il subissent en tant
qu'entreprise en raison de ses
publicités frauduleuses là et beaucoup
plus important que l'argent qu'ils font
grâce aux publicités mais il y a
beaucoup d'experts qui jettent de doute
là-dessus quand même la grosse partie de
leur revenu vient de la publicité qui
vont offrir mais justement vu que c'est
là qu'ils font leur argent il y a pas
investi dans la validation puisque je
pense à ce qu'on peut voir de la
validation de qui se retrouve derrière
cette publicité là ils savent
l'influence puis le pouvoir que les
autres ils ont ils sont très très au
courant c'est comme ça qui continuent à
faire des millions et est-ce que
facebook retire les publicités en
question généralement quand on signale
des forces publicités à Facebook il les
retire assez rapidement là n'est pas le
problème c'est que c'est un problème
systématique les fraudeurs derrière ces
publicités là continuez en en mettre en
ligne et ils sont pas avoir d'efforts
systématique de la part de Facebook
d’essayer des éliminer il continue
jour après jour jour après jour d'être
mise en ligne c'est publicité là et
c'est exactement la même chose les mêmes
images le même texte qu'on a constaté
l'année dernière nous avons présenté
plusieurs de ces fausses publicités à
Hakim Laniel la Nani il est cofondateur
de la clinique de cybercriminiologie de
l'Université de Montréal une entité qui
offre du soutien aux victimes de
cybercriminalité
un profil facebook qui est un peu panier
dans ce vortex là justement je voulais
juste comme tellement
ce que tu en pensais comme là tu vois
nous on a un faux profil facebook qui
est particulièrement visé par ses
fraudes
d'investissement des lendemain
dès que je défile j'ai des publications
quand quand tu vois ça qu'est-ce que ça
te fait dire finalement ils font
absolument rien pour lutter contre ça
parce que nous en deux secondes on est
capable despoter puis de d'avoir un gros
doute sur la légitimité de cette annonce
là au départ avec une un doute
raisonnable de croire que c'est
potentiellement frauduleux pourquoi
est-ce que tu la laisses devenir live
pourquoi est-ce que cela met pas en
suspens car Instagram a une politique
par rapport au contenu qui est un petit
peu trop osé qui est un petit peu trop
nu si c'est pas de là ça va pas être
permis justement de le diffuser il y a
du contrôle qui est fait sur ces
publications là sur ces sur ces annonces
là pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas la
c'est pas une réalité quand on parle
justement de stratagème potentiellement
frauduleux avec des sites
potentiellement faux et non seulement
Facebook fait de l'argent avec ses
publicités là mais c'est vraiment un
outil selon des experts qui ont de
parler qui est très utile au fraudeur le
système publicitaire de Facebook ça
permet de cibler les gens de manière
ultra pointue et ce qu'on constate que
quand quelqu'un s'intéresse à ses
publicités là on leur en sert de plus en
plus on sait pas vraiment comment
fonctionne la plateforme publicitaire de
Facebook par contre on a des témoignages
de criminels qui explique que
facebook
propose les publicités contenant des
arnaques à des personnes qui sont
susceptibles de cliquer sur ces arnaques
donc par exemple si vous avez une fois
cliqué sur une arnaque Facebook c'est
que vous êtes susceptible de le refaire
et donc vous allez avoir une avalanche
de publicité pour des arnaques dans
votre flux d'actualité dexclic ou que tu
aperçois
une publicité frauduleuse sur les médias
sociaux ou sur sur Google toutes les
moteurs de recherche qui existent tu vas
tomber dans un siphon dans un siphon qui
va te pousser des publicités qui vont
ressembler à celle-là puis on va avoir
d'autres puis on va en voir d'autres et
on va avoir d'autres et on va dire ça
fait 4 5 publicités que je vois comme ça
puis que je vois que du monde qui
bénéficie de cette offre-là moi j'ai pas
le goût de passer à côté de ça fait
longtemps on rentre dans le fear
Messenger sur encore une fois sur un
autre attachant qui est utilisé puis
c'est ça que ça crée dans le fond c'est
c'est publicités là puis le
fonctionnement de ces algorithmes
algorithmes les utilisent dans ce
contexte là c'est que ça crée cette
période de manquer à côté d'un
opportunité puis là on est attiré puis
on va le faire la société mère de
facebook meta a répondu de façon très
vague à nos questions pourtant très
précises sur la présence de publicité
frauduleuse sur sa plateforme dans une
déclaration écrite un de ses
porte-paroles affirme que l'entreprise
consacre des ressources importantes à la
résolution de ce problème nous
continuerons et écrit-il à dire dans ce
travail pour protéger les personnes sur
nos plateformes contre ces excroqués on
voit que les armes là que facebook
utilise pour combattre ce problème là
c'est un peu arménagal avec les
fraudeurs Facebook nous dit par exemple
quand une publicité va l'encontre de ces
conditions d'utilisation ils vont soit
bloquer la page ou bloquer le compte de
publicitaire de cette page là ben ce
qu'on nous on constate c'est que les
fraudeurs utilisent des pages qui ont
été volées ou qui ont été piratés donc
que leur page Facebook fassent bloquer
ça change rien ils vont aller en acheter
d'autres où ils vont aller en pirater
d'autres pour mettre d'autres publicités
en ligne donc c'est comme essayer
d'éteindre un incendie avec un pistolet
à eau en fait
j'espère ré que les policiers la police
ou les gouvernements et pour mettre
davantage de ressources là-dedans pour
parce que c'est c'est il y a personne
qui peut les arrêter on est comme au Far
West là c'est comme les bandits se
promènent puis le shérif est passé pas
assez fort pour les arrêter la grande
grande difficulté c'est que
il y a une portée ou un effet très
limité aux actes qu'on peut porter sur
une base locale ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est d'identifier où est-ce qu'ils sont
ces gens-là puis est-ce qu'on peut
intervenir concrètement avec nos
collègues ailleurs dans le monde pour
les empêcher de continuer de le faire
maintenant qu'on a établi et expliqué
que ce type de fraude se perpétue la
question tout naturelle que se pose tout
le monde est-ce que les autorités ici le
savent et si oui qu'est-ce qu'elles font
si elles font quelque chose de toutes
les entités canadiennes qui ont un
pouvoir d'agir contre ces fraude là la
seule qui nous a répondu c'est
l'Autorité des marchés financiers au
Québec donc l'AMF l'AMF avec ses
collègues à l'international
l'orgasme s'appelle loïcvm sont en train
de voir avec leurs collègues de partout
dans le monde si des publicités pour des
produits financiers diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux
doivent d'abord passer par un régulateur
comme la MS le problème avec ça c'est
que les entités qui offrent des services
en crypto monnaie au Canada qui veulent
annoncer sur les réseaux sociaux doivent
déjà avoir une autorisation du canal le
canal qui est le centre d'analyse des
opérations et des déclarations
financières du Canada qui n'est pas un
régulateur mais qui peut quand même
émettre des permis à ces entreprises là
pour opérer au pays donc que ce soit le
canal qui émet ce document là que ce
soit l'AMF la différence n'est pas tout
à fait claire et l'AMF ne m'a même pas
pu répondre à nos questions à ce
sujet-là parce que le nœud du problème
c'est que ces gens-là contournent les
mécanismes en place et mettre des
publicités frauduleuse sur le site donc
est-ce que ce contrôle là réglerait
quelque chose on peut se poser des
questions là-dessus
nous avons réussi à descendre le groupe
au complet grâce à une journée d'action
qui a eu lieu en janvier 2021 à
l'étranger il y a quand même des choses
qui se font et des conséquences qui
subissent ces acteurs frauduleux ouais
donc on a parlé à vos pôles qui servent
de police de l'Union européenne qui
recoupe le 50 pays le Canada d'ailleurs
est partenaire de RuPaul Europa a
commencé à effectuer des descentes dans
les centres d'appels qui mènent ces
fraudes donc on a vu descendre dans des
pays comme la Lituanie la Bulgarie
l'Ukraine au cours des dernières années
des centaines d'arrestations des
millions de dollars qui ont été saisis
et d'ailleurs dans ces centres d'appels
là il y avait des victimes canadiennes
ce qu'on nous a expliqué c'est que ce
sont des enquêtes qui sont extrêmement
complexes parce que les fraudeurs
opèrent dans plein de pays différents
ils vont viser des pays dans lequel ils
n'opèrent pas donc un centre d'appel en
Bulgarie va viser le Canada par exemple
donc ça devient difficile là pour les
autorités d'effectuer des enquêtes comme
ça faut se rappeler c'est une immense
industrie qui génère des milliards des
milliards de dollars par année comme
nous disait la journaliste israélienne
c'est Mona one glass l'année dernière
c'est le Hubert de la fraude c'est
appliqué là les méthodes de la Big tech
à la fraude nous européen ce que nous
faisons c'est vraiment essayer d'aller
après l'état de pensante pour être sûr
que lorsque nous menons des journées
d'action ce séjour là et l'effet le plus
important possible après les groupes
criminels essayent toujours d'opérer
sans vraiment connaître les frontières
et Europole avec les partenaires nous
travaillons de manière concertée pour
leur envoyer un message très fort que
nous aussi les forces de l'ordre somme
capables de travailler sans connaître de
frontières
reste que si jamais les autorités d'ici
veulent s'inspirer de ce qui se fait
ailleurs on a un petit exemple alors
soumettre celui d'Australie oui en
Australie c'est l'équivalent du Bureau
de la concurrence donc le age aussi qui
a décidé de poursuivre Facebook donc
Facebook se retrouve pour la première
fois sur les bancs des accusés et
scalègle et trip aussi en Australie
c'est que Facebook est en fait complice
de ces fraudeurs là parce qu'il a été
averti de l'étendue de ce problème-là sa
plateforme à de multiples reprises et
qu'il n'a pas agi même s'il avait le
devoir de le faire on sait pas
exactement quelle forme ça prendra
Facebook est trouvé coupable puis ça
change complètement la donne parce que
ce qu'ils disent en Australie ce que
Facebook devrait être responsable du
contenu qui est mis sur sa plateforme
que Facebook a une responsabilité alors
ce n'est pas qu'un intermédiaire alors
qu'aux États-Unis par exemple la loi
définit Facebook comme un intermédiaire
et beaucoup de pays appliquent cette
même logique à Facebook donc ça ça
pourrait vraiment changer la donne à
l'international et faire bouger les
choses même ailleurs dans le monde dans
le cas du Canada le Bureau de la
concurrence nous a simplement dit qu'il
ne commentait pas sur des enquêtes en
cours et tous les ministères qui
pourraient agir à cet effet-là non pas
voulu accorder d'entrevue à nos
collègues de la facture
on sent comme abandonné par tout le
monde autrement il y a personne qui peut
nous aider absolument à personne qui
peut rien faire alors on se sent
vraiment tout seul
abandonné
dans beaucoup de d'organismes publics
c'est de se croiser bras puis d'attendre
que les plaintes arrivent et s'il y a
pas de plainte on pense qu'il y a pas de
problème alors que l'attitude qui serait
conséquente avec ce que c'est devenu
désormais internet ce serait d'être
beaucoup plus proactif avoir des
systèmes de veille pour
regarder ce qui se passe sur le réseau
et éventuellement dessiner des possibles
fraudes avant même qu'elle se produit ça
avec ça on protégerait véritablement
les citoyens si on revenait au coeur de
cette histoire c'est à dire aux victimes
qui perdent beaucoup de sous qui se
sentent abandonnés impuissante qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire sur les
devant quoi ces victimes se retrouvent
maintenant que le fait est accompli
est-ce qu'il nous est dit c'est qu'elle
se sente assez impuissante par rapport à
ça qu'il y a pas grand monde qui est là
pour les aider qui a pas grand espoir de
récupérer leur argent il y a plusieurs
raisons pour ça notamment le caractère
international de la fraude dans un parlé
plus tôt mais c'est aussi le fait que
les autorités et ça revient à chaque
fois qu'on parle d'histoire de fraude on
sait vraiment pas les ressources à
consacrer à ça pourquoi que nous
organisations en place comme la MF la
GRC 236 fraude un petit organisations-là
qui ont pas nécessairement les
ressources illimitées pour intervenir
puis pour tout faire mais c'est que ça
vient pas juste deux ça vient d'un
changement de loi ça vient d'une
pression exercée sur nos élus pour
justement rendre
de rendre puis faire une prise de
conscience comme quoi que investir dans
la lutte à se bat criminalité et
nécessaire parce que on le voit l'impact
que ça là est immense puisqu'il a été
Forever grandissant ça s'arrête pas puis
on a aucune indication comme quoi que ça
va ça va ça moindre avec le temps ce
qu'on entend aussi le côté des victimes
c'est qu'ils sentent comme si on les
blancs mais d'être tombé dans le piège
d'une fraude quand on dit aux gens le
fait bien vous recherchent en investir
ce qu'il faut comprendre là c'est que
les fraudeurs sont très très bons pour
apparaître dans les résultats de
recherche Google par exemple ça c'est
une fraude bien connue quantum supposons
que tu tombes là-dessus tu dis bon je
dois faire une recherche sur Google pour
voir si c'est une bonne un bon
investissement tous les résultats sur la
première page de Google sauf un ce sont
associés à ces fraudes donc n'importe
quel de signer là sur lequel on clique
sauf un seul ça va être un faux article
ou quelque chose comme ça qui va nous
dire oui quantum
donc pour quelqu'un qui est peut-être la
misère à l'Irlandais par exemple
quelqu'un qui est peut-être pas super
bien habilité sur le web
ça la légitime tous les résultats disent
que c'est super bon donc quand on dit
aux gens de bien faire leurs recherches
c'est une fausse solution parce que les
fraudeurs ont déjà pensé à ça on parle
beaucoup de Facebook dans tout ça et de
comment qui engrange des sous avec ça
mais les premiers résultats ce sont des
résultats frauduleux commandité donc
Google aussi le vend des pubs
frauduleuses dans tout ça et Google
aussi disent faire des efforts mais
malgré tout c'est encore là les lois ont
pas été mise à niveau les lois
essentiellement ont été conçus pour
permettre aux plateformes de se
développer en les protégeant d'une trop
grande responsabilité
l'effet pervers de ça c'est évidemment
il y en a qui l'ont utilisé pour
diffuser du des messages produits
poursuivant maintenant Nicolas sur une
autre entité qui est pas un pouvoir très
grand dans tout ça mais qui tout de même
pourrait jouer un rôle important c'est
le centre antifo du Canada oui le centre
anti fraude est hab également la
première ressource vers laquelle les
victimes se font diriger par les
autorités on peut avoir l'impression
peut-être que le centre anti fraude son
travail c'est d'agir pour enquêter sur
ces fraudes-là maintenant
essentiellement ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils compilent des données à des
autorité dans leurs enquêtes et prennent
le coup de ce qui se passe au pays vont
aussi ils mettent des avertissements sur
leur site web mais ils n'ont pas
nécessairement le pouvoir d'agir dans
tout ça l'information va peut-être pas
vous emmener des résultats immédiatement
pour des victimes mais ça peut aider à
prévenir des pertes verte d'autres
victimes à partir de cette information
là ou sinon cette information-là peut
être complémentaire ou sinon aidé à
initier d'autres actions qui pourraient
nous permettre de diminuer l'impact
négatif la faute
[Musique]